the American Music Awards tore up our TV
screens Sunday night here are the most
standout moments host gigi hadid wowed
with her fashion of course but also did
a pretty solid Melania Trump impression
I my husband President Barack Obama I
know children sasha and malia and her co
host Saturday Night Live Star Jay
Pharoah is a master of impressions
Sunday he nailed both Kanye West I'm a
better rider than dr. Seuss fam and
Taylor Swift in her apple commercial
Jumpman Jumpman Jumpman you don't have
to call i hit my dance like Usher
and Jay wasn't the only one Drake
debuted his own commercial during the
show complete with a nod to tswift and
we're told everyone in the audience was
clapping and cheering for the ad though
Teyana Taylor had a slightly more
difficult go of it the Fayette video
vixen almost took a tumble on stage
Nicki Minaj was steady on her feet but
also used her hands in a very
interesting way we've censored the
moment they fill in me gives the rope
and I got chilly but the night wasn't
all funny moments and outrageous
performances the late singer prince's
sister took to the stage and had the
audience in tears until we see you again
this is for you
you